it's the end of the road for the ethnic
Armenians of Azerbaijan who for
centuries have made their home in his
mountains and Beyond
with the separatist Enclave of
nagorno-karabakh now under azerbaijani
control the 120 000 remaining ethnic
Armenians were told they could stay and
be ruled from Baku or leave
it set off an exodus while neighboring
Armenia where more than twenty thousand
have arrived since Sunday
I don't think we will be able to return
to karabakh how how can we go back after
all of this happened we can't live with
them
these Armenians are proud angry and
upset Russian peacekeepers failed to
stop Azerbaijan blocking the main road
to Armenia for nine months they refused
to accept Aid that was offered via a
longer route controlled by Azerbaijan
the Europeans are accused of not wanting
to pressurize oil and gas rate transabai
Janam yes
I don't know what kind of chess game
this is I left everything in my home a
ton of potatoes in my cellar honey
everything was there I know I will make
a new life but it won't be the same I
curse the one who made us like this
the US government says azerbaijan's use
of force to take control of
nagorno-karabakh was unacceptable we
know that there are injured
civilians
in nagorno-karabakh
who need to be evacuated
and it is absolutely essential that
evacuation be facilitated by the
government of Azerbaijan azerbaijan's
president ilham Alief says his Iron Fist
has consigned the idea of the Region's
Independence to history
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera on the Armenia
Azerbaijan board
two Kosovo serbs
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera